le travail se fait en équipe nettoyez
préparer et séchez les boîtes en
plastique qui seront ensuite utilisés
pour le vrac alimentaire et l'impression
d'être dans une entreprise classique
pourtant les travailleurs sont en
situation de handicap
ils sont plus de 150 dans cet
établissement spécialisé pour la plupart
ils sont polyvalents voir
multicompétence c'est à dire que ben ils
peuvent travailler dans cet atelier a
sur un process spécifiques de lavage de
boîte mais ils peuvent aller dans un
autre atelier après pour faire autre
chose dans cette structure près d'une
trentaine de métiers sont proposés de la
blanchisserie avec une machine qui
repasse elle même les chemises ou de la
sous traitance industrielle pour des
missions de conditionnement ou de la
préparation de commandes
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que quand ils sortent de les at il y ait
peu de différence entre ce qu'ils ont
vécu et les ath et ce qu'il pourrait
vivre dans une entreprise dite normale
pour faciliter l'insertion
professionnelle des travailleurs
l'établissement est aussi doté d'un
espace médico-social sept personnes
présentes pour accompagner et répondre à
des besoins parfois spécifiques qu'on
est quand même d'un accompagnement
adapté de la personne donc oui c'est
qu'on va prendre à temps avec la
personne quand ça va pas bien pour
comprendre pourquoi swaps et sur le plan
personnel mais aussi le plan de travail
différents collègues 35 heures de
travail par semaine et une rémunération
égale à un smic
une fois l'ensemble des allocations
additionner 24 établissements de ce
genre sont présents sur le département
des yvelines pour un taux d'insertion
professionnelle inférieur à 5%